mais amine des mois ouais je serai pas
le gêner c'est comment tu sais je sais
pas c'est vraiment fantastique un petit
[Musique]
le drapeau algérien il a notamment été
souvent associé aux compétitions
sportives alors que c'est d'abord un
symbole de lutte c'est le symbole de
l'indépendance et de la lutte pour
l'indépendance du peuple algérien contre
le colonialisme français où ces drapeaux
bleu blanc rouge qui a flotté pendant
longtemps en algérie et ça a été vécue
comme un traumatisme par beaucoup
d'algériens le drapeau algérien avant
d'être celui de l'état contemporain
il est d'abord celui d'un mouvement
politique qui a été dirigée par une
figure aussi importante que controversé
qui s'appelle le message
le croissant et l'étoile ce sont des
symboles qui sont liées à la culture
arabo-islamique la couleur verte c'est
la couleur préférée du prophète de
l'islam couleur blanche plutôt la pureté
le rouge
la vigueur sauf que ça signifie
également ça peut signifier également le
vert couleur de l'islam l'encore leblanc
l'indépendance et le rouge le sang des
martyrs et pour d'autres ça peut
signifier dans une perspective on va
dire maghrébine le verre ça va deux
tunis le rouge marrakech et le blanc
alger le premier drapeau algérien celui
qu'on prenait un peu près dans sa forme
actuelle auraient été cousus par une
française qui s'appelait emilie bus
quand et qui était la femme de messali
alors ml bus quand pourquoi c'est
scandaleux c'est une femme c'est une
française d'origine populaire et qui en
plus est marié à au père fondateur du
nationalisme et qui va être le qui va
être très vite des classes est dénigrée
dans quelque chose assez sulfureux dans
cette origine un qui est une hypothèse
mais qui n'hypothèque assez assez
crédible assez importante et qui fait
que sont les récits on va mettre cette
histoire en avant ou alors on voit
plutôt les facettes il a des événements
très dur très douloureux très
traumatisant dans l'histoire du peuple
algérien qui vont qui vont expliquer
justement
ce le fait que ce drapeau devienne un
symbole de la lutte et du sacrifice du
peuple algérien contre le collège
français
on peut citer notamment ce qui va se
passer en mai 45
les algériens comme beaucoup d'autres
vont célébrer la défaite du nazisme et
vont notamment à sétif dans l'est de
l'algérie faire une manifestation où le
drapeau algérien tel qu'on le connaît va
être brandie et ça va être l'origine
d'incidents de répression et de
massacres massifs les massacres pardon
du conte du nord constantinois
il y aura des dizaines de milliers de
morts cet événement traumatisant pour
pour une génération va associer je pense
définitivement ce drapeau à la lutte du
peuple algérien contre le colonialisme
ce drapeau va être de plus en plus connu
de plus en plus populaire de telle sorte
que notamment lors des manifestations
spontanées et grandiose de décembre 60
le drapeau va être sorti brandie par les
algériens qu'il avait cousu
clandestinement
[Musique]
je
en france en tout cas dans la diaspora
sachant qu'en france la communauté
étrangère la plus importante sont les
algériens
c'est aussi pourquoi on va plus souvent
voir dans des célébrations privé dans
des manifestations publiques ou
sportives même compte a priori le de
leur apport et diana aucun rapport avec
certains de se passer mais les personnes
qui vont de brandir je pense que c'est
en fait le symbole d'un attachement à un
pays perdu au pays des ancêtres
[Musique]
ils vont exprimer par là le fait qu'ils
ont été privés de leur indépendance 162
par un régime autoritaire et que
justement ils vont essayer de fermer
cette parenthèse en tout cas ils
prétendent on peut vraiment dire qui a
une histoire officielle ou qui a des en
algérie jusqu'à une certaine période
d'ailleurs c'était plutôt la culture de
l'effacement et du silence justement
pour ne pas réveiller des symboles
controversée du passé qui ont été
effacées ou marginalisés ou écrasés par
d'autres tendances politiques parler des
origines du drapeau aurait signifié pour
les autorités algériennes et bien
d'évoquer sur ce les aurait obligés à
évoquer la figure de messali hadj et par
exemple qui était une figure pionnière
mais aussi qui a été marginalisé écrasé
par le fln donc c'est pour ça qu'il est
parfois compliqué de trouver des
éléments factuels précis sur autour de
ce drapeau est autour de cette histoire